hey everybody welcome to the show thanks
for watching so London's mayor is
dealing with a pretty big problem they
have this wave of violence in the city
it's murder rates has now topped New
York cities and this is in spite of the
fact or maybe partly because of the fact
that they have banned guns in the city
some of the strictest gun laws in the
entire world
yet the murder rate is spiking and
there's all this violent crime you took
away the guns and now people are just
running around stabbing each other left
and right apparently so mayor Khan the
mayor of London you know he got his
brain trust together and they were
talking about it and they said what can
we do about this we took away the guns
now people are just stabbing each other
what do we do about all the stabbings
and then someone said I don't know who
but somebody said oh I've got it
listen to this brilliant plan what we do
is we ban the knives
what's Jay and everyone else said oh why
didn't I think of that perfect yeah we
just get let's just keep getting rid of
objects until there are no objects left
so Mayor Khan sent out a tweet a few
days ago where he said no excuses there
is never a reason to carry a knife never
a reason no you can't think of a single
reason mayor Khan has never been to an
Outback Steakhouse he's never been to
any other restaurant at all he's never
been in a kitchen okay he can't think of
a reason why anyone would ever use a
knife now I'm a member of the the knife
carrying community I admit and here's
here's the crazy thing I can think of I
come across probably dozens of different
uses in a day for this knife and none of
them involve killing anybody
it's just that net I've never killed
anyone with this knife even though I've
carried it around instead I just do
other things with it by the way I'm
gonna swing this knife around via for
the rest of the video which actually I
probably shouldn't do that because
someone will call the cops they'll see
me they'll see
a guy in his car swinging a knife around
and yelling to himself and look call the
police so I won't do that but I find
many uses for the knife that don't
involve killing people in fact I would
probably argue that almost every human
adult's in the world uses a knife for
non murdering activities on a relatively
frequent basis a knife is one of the
most basic tools that mankind has had at
its disposal for thousands of years so
if we're gonna start going after knives
then well then it's then pretty much
it's it's game on
and that's where I mean we can have a
lot of fun with this and try to mock and
parody but it's hard to do it so it's
it's the the gun grabbing on the left
has now transcended parody I mean I
wrote something yesterday I wrote a
piece yesterday where I was listing okay
here are seven other items that London
will have to ban next after it gets rid
of the guns and the knives and just
obvious things like for instance other
kitchen utensils forks I mean you have
no idea how and I did some research into
this okay I took this seriously I'd
really did some research and I
discovered that fork violence is an
epidemic across the West there are so
many cases of people using Forks to stab
people
chairs chair violence is a huge problem
in our schools also a big problem among
WWE wrestlers it's just people are using
chairs all the time to hit each other
rocks obviously people die from rocks
being thrown at them rocks falling on
them they die in rock climbing accidents
they die at rock concerts a rock killed
all the dinosaurs I mean rocks are you
could argue that the rock is the most
deadly object in in history and so we're
going to start digging up all the rocks
from under the earth and take all the
rocks from on top of the earth and get
rid of them hands I mean that this is
the most easily the deadliest most
objectionable weapon in the world even
more so than the rock is the human hand
hands kill at least in America hands
kill more people every year than rifles
or shotguns and not to mention the fact
that the hand is involved in every act
of violence even when you're using a gun
so now I'm not proposing that we
actually confiscate all the hands that
would be ridiculous what I'm saying is
you get your hands registered ahead of
time you go through a licensing process
there are certain you know state
sanctioned activities that you can use
your hands for if you use your hand at a
non-sanctioned activity then you get
your hands confiscated temporarily until
you take a few classes we could even
call it hands-on classes or something
like that we could work with that but
and you can take some classes and then
you get your hands back for a
probationary period I mean these are
just some ideas okay
but we could get into all that trying to
highlight the absurdity of this what I
really like to do instead is to try to
understand where this comes from
why do some people put this incredible
emphasis on objects why do they set out
to fight violence and evil by banning
the objects that are sometimes used in
those acts of violence and evil why
can't they see what you and I see which
is that once you start telling this road
you really do have to get rid of all
objects on earth because anything can be
used in the in an act of violence but
why do some people struggle with this
why do they infuse all of this moral
significance into an object and I think
the answer is very simple there are a
few answers but I think the primary
thing is a misunderstanding of human
nature and this is really what what lies
at the at the root this is the source of
many of our debates in this culture it's
that the left does not understand human
nature doesn't understand how human
beings work which is kind of fascinating
because they are human beings themselves
so all they have to do is look within
themselves and they should be able to
answer a lot
their questions but but they don't for
whatever reason they don't they don't
have a lot of introspection so it's kind
of ironic or it seems ironic anyway that
those who understand that human beings
are corrupted prone to evil often can't
be trusted you know the people in that
camp they're the ones who are saying no
don't take our guns away there they're
the ones who are pro-gun rights while
the ones who believe that human beings
are not a fallen race and are not
corrupted and are kind of these blank
slates morally speaking they're the ones
who are saying you got to keep us away
from guns you would think would be the
opposite but it isn't because those of
us who understand human nature
understand two things number one very
simply we know that we have to have a
means to protect ourselves from our
fellow fallen man we have a healthy
suspicion of other people because we
know how people are and how they've
always been and always will be until the
end of time we know that because we can
see other people we've read history we
know how people are we also have a
healthy suspicion of the state because
the state is comprised not of these
benevolent gods but of people of
fallible fallen people so we have and
now we've put them in positions of power
and control so that makes us even more
suspicious of them we don't hate people
we just understand them and so we wish
to equip ourselves accordingly but the
second thing this is the more important
thing we know that fallen men will
always be prone to hurt each other a man
I think even more so a man who wants to
do harm to another person will do it or
at least attempt it there's not a lot
you can do this is human nature the
reason why the vast majority of people
on earth have never committed a murder
have never raped have never
done some hideously violent thing you
know what the reason is what why haven't
most people done that it's not because
the law it's not because of regulations
it's not because they didn't have access
to this or that tool it's because they
never wanted to the vast majority of
people have never used a gun to kill
anybody it's not because they couldn't
get their hands on a gun it's because
they just never it they have no interest
in killing anyone they's just not
something that ever comes up they have
they haven't they don't even have any
temptation in that regard so it's not
even that they have a moral objection to
it they they have a moral objection to
it as well mm-hmm but the primary reason
why they haven't killed anyone
it's that they just it's never even
comes up they don't want to they are
stopped not by the law they're stopped
by the fact that they are not so
depraved as to desire to kill another
person but here's where the problem
comes in when you've got a man who has
descended into that state when he's
gotten to the point where he really
wants to kill somebody now just imagine
being in this state psychologically and
spiritually and I know people will joke
around and say oh I want to kill that
guy I'm gonna kill you I'm talking about
actually being in a state of mind where
you really literally want to end
somebody's life that's a very dark place
to be in once you get there it seems
like it's not a far leap to go from
there to I don't care about the
repercussions in fact with these mass
killers and serial killers the
repercussions that's part of the appeal
they want to die they want their life to
be over or they want to go to jail they
want attention and so there's no there's
no disincentive there at all so once you
get to that point once you get to the
point where you want to kill somebody
you don't care about the punishment
after the fact or in fact you want the
punishment then there's just the law
really there's there's almost nothing
the law can do at that point with
somebody like that that is just a
dangerous person who's a ticking time
bomb is gonna and is gonna explode the
only way the law can really do anything
preemptively is if the person announces
ahead of time that hey guess what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna kill somebody but
what we found is that even when they do
that which is basically what the what
the the guy in Florida did even then the
law seems impotent the law seems unable
to do anything even when they have an
opportunity but most people who are
violent they never make that
announcement ahead of time they just do
it one day so that's the fact no matter
what you do you could take away my knife
you can take away my gun but if I
decided that I'm gonna kill somebody
today I can do it I can get out of the
car right now and do it affect I don't
have to get out of the car I could use
the car would be very easy to do anyone
can the only thing that stops me or the
primary thing that stops me is that I
have I just I'm no desire to do that
whatsoever
I'm not a murderous person but there are
people who are murderers what do we do
about them that's the question that's
the way we have to frame this discussion
we have to acknowledge that there are
violent people out out there with a very
dark evil in their souls and a very dark
desire what do we do about those people
the gun control side says well we got to
stave them off with the law that's what
we do we you know that's the the
fortress that we set up around ourselves
is the law and maybe after a while we
can even change them with the law and if
we become a gun-free Society they're
gonna become less violent because there
are let there are fewer violent objects
around and so they're not going to be
influenced in that direction and they'll
become better people and so we have the
law and that's what we're going to do
the Second Amendment side says well the
law is ineffective
once we get to this point once a guy has
crossed this threshold within himself
psychologically and spiritually once
he's gotten to the point where he really
wants to kill somebody and he doesn't
care about the repercussions that's the
threshold once he's crossed it there's
nothing the law can do I can't you know
I walk it down the street I pass by
people you go somewhere in public you go
to a movie theater you send your kids to
school you can never know whether
whether or not somebody that you're
passing by on the street is a person who
has crossed that threshold there's no
way of knowing so I don't want to be
reliant on the law to stop them
because the law can't follow me around
the law itself is not a physical barrier
protecting me
and I can't have cops following me
around every second of the day unless
you're a celebrity or fame or a
politician
then you're not blessed enough to have
an armed security detail but even just
think about that for a minute think
about the President of the United States
has this whole small army of people who
are dedicated to keeping him alive and
why is that it's because the president
United States no matter who the
president is it's because of his office
that the President of the United States
is somebody who many other people in the
world want to kill every second that the
president is alive there are probably
hundreds if not thousands of people in
the world who are actively plotting his
demise and if they ever got the
opportunity would absolutely kill him so
think about the effort even though it's
definitely illegal to kill the president
so we've got all the laws in place but
even in spite of that still there is
this incredible effort required just to
keep this one guy alive you gotta have
this he has this whole small army that
surround him and then anytime he goes
somewhere in public that the Army has to
go there
ahead of time and sweep the area and set
up security details and everything else
it's just an enormous round the clock
24/7 never sleeping effort to keep this
man alive
which just shows you how necessary it is
to have a means to protect ourselves the
old you want to know why you and I are
still alive for most of us the only
reason why we're why you and I are still
alive it's because nobody has ever
wanted really to kill us but if anyone
ever made up their minds has said I want
to kill that guy and if they ever said
that about you then you're in trouble
that's why and certainly the law is not
going to be able to do anything for you
the moment you come face-to-face with
that guy who wants to kill you the law
just melts away and it's gone it might
as well it might as well not even exist
and you have to have the means to
protect yourself and your children the
left does not understand the Fallen
nature of man does not understand how
evil functions doesn't even understand
that evil exists in the first place and
so it has this this abiding faith in the
state's ability to change human behavior
and to cure what ills man deep down in
his heart so they think it's as simple
as the state banning weapons and and and
setting up gun-free zones and maybe
putting out some PSAs where they say
tisk tisk tisk don't shoot people now
okay don't do that it's bad and that
will be enough in their minds to sway to
control the collective which is
comprised of these individuals who are
not you know inherently corrupted but
are these blank slates who just are
waiting around to be herded or or sent
in one direction or another the
intrinsic corruption in the mind of a
leftist the intrinsic corruption is in
the object not the person and so the
object a gun in the mind of a leftist is
kind of like the ring in Lord of the
Rings and it will do to a person what
the ring did to Gollum you take an
innocent person you put this object in
their hands and it starts to change them
but obviously it's not actually that
simple so here is what can be done aside
from giving us the tools to protect our
because the law can do very little but I
agree that preferably we don't even want
to get to that point it would be nice if
there was something preemptively we
could do so that a guy doesn't even get
to the point where he wants to kill
another person and the only thing
that'll stop him from killing me is if I
can shoot him first I'd prefer if it
never got to that point so what can we
do
aside from arming ourselves to defend
ourselves and our family
I think after we've done that if we
really want to cut down on violence then
we have to cut down on the inclination
towards violence which means we have to
give people a proper moral formation
okay the proper moral formation of the
individual the inclination to violence
is a problem of moral and spiritual
formation or deformation we need to be
morally formed which starts in the
family especially with the fathers who
often are not in the picture when it
comes to violent people and also the
church you know the problem the real
problem is that we live in a disordered
depraved degenerate empty culture and
people are born into it and they're born
into these broken homes and they go out
looking for moral formation all they
find is moral mutation and they end up
with disordered desires degenerate
desires and they have no reason not to
go out and try to fulfill those desires
so I'll tell you what the state can
really do it can realize that the
institutions in the culture who should
primarily be in charge of moral
formation are the family and the church
and so the state can offer proper
support to the family and with the
church it can just stay out of the way
this is what religious liberty is all
about stay out of the way and let the
church do what the church does or is
supposed to do
that's what we should be relying on
those two institutions if you really
want to cut down on violence that's
where you have to turn not to the
government not to the law I think that's
a pretty great combination when it comes
in it won't be perfect but when it comes
to combating violence and the combating
evil generally give individuals the
ability to protect themselves strong
family strong churches I'm telling you
if you have that going for you if you
have those three things going for you
you're going to be in the safest
possible human society it will not be
utopian it won't be perfect but it will
be the safest and most ordered society
possible but unfortunately the left is
kind of trying to do the opposite of
that they want to have it both ways they
want to destroy the church break down
the family the two institutions that are
in charge of moral formation are most in
charge of it and then they act with they
react with shock and horror when they
see all of these sociopaths and killers
and evil people in our midst but it goes
back to a misunderstanding of human
nature all right that's it for me today
guys thanks for watching and have a
great day